En fait,
j'ai pris un chemin qui n'était pas
celui que mes parents avaient imaginé.
A 19 ans, j'ai abandonné l'université --
abandonné, viré, coupant les cheveux en quatre.
(Rires)
Je suis parti en tournée en tant que joueur professionnel de cor,
ce qui était mon rêve de toujours.
J'ai joué de la musique de chambre à travers les États-Unis et l'Europe,
j'ai été 2 ans en tournée
avec un grand joueur de jazz : Charlie Bird.
Approchant de mes 30 ans,
j'ai fini membre de l'orchestre symphonique de Barcelone.
Quelle vie !
Mes parents ne se sont jamais plaints.
Ils m'ont soutenu tout du long.
Ce n'était pas leur rêve.
Ils disaient à leurs voisins et amis :
« Notre fils prend une décennie sabbatique. »
(Rires)
Et --
Il y a eu, cependant, une conversation embarrassante sur mon style de vie
dont j'aimerais vous parler.
J'avais 27 ans, j'étais rentré de Barcelone,
j'étais chez mes parents pour Noël,
je préparais le dîner avec ma mère et nous étions seuls dans la cuisine.
Et elle était silencieuse, trop silencieuse.
Quelque chose clochait.
J'ai dit : « Maman, à quoi penses-tu ? »
Elle a dit : « Ton père et moi sommes inquiets pour toi. »
J'ai dit : « Quoi ? » Qu'est-ce que ça pouvait être ?
Et elle a dit : « Je veux que tu sois complètement honnête :
as-tu voté républicain ? »
(Rires)
En fait,
je n'étais pas très politique, j'étais juste un joueur de cor.
J'ai eu une épiphanie,
ils l'avaient perçu et cela causait de la confusion.
J'étais devenu un enthousiaste du capitalisme
et je veux vous expliquer ce que c'est.
Cela est né de l'intérêt que j'ai toujours eu
pour, croyez-le ou non, la pauvreté.
Quand j'étais enfant, en grandissant à Seattle,
je me souviens de la première fois où j'ai vu la vraie pauvreté.
Nous étions une famille du bas de la classe moyenne,
mais, bien sûr, ce n'est pas de la vraie pauvreté.
C'en est même loin.
La première fois que j'ai vu la pauvreté et son visage,
j'avais 6 ou 7 ans, au début des années 70.
Et, comme pour nombre d'entre vous, c'était un exemple prosaïque et banal.
C'était une photographie dans National Geographic
d'un enfant de mon âge à l'est de l'Afrique,
il y avait des mouches sur son visage et un ventre distendu.
Il n'allait pas s'en sortir, je le savais et j'étais impuissant.
Certains d'entre vous se souviennent de cette image,
pas exactement celle-ci, mais une similaire.
Elle a révélé la misère noire à l'Occident.
Cette vision m'a hanté alors que je grandissais, allais à l'école,
abandonnais, faisais autre chose
et fondais une famille.
Et je me demandais ce qu'il était arrivé à cet enfant
ou aux autres comme lui partout dans le monde.
J'ai étudié, même si je n'étais pas à l'université,
je cherchais une réponse :
qu'arrivait-il aux personnes les plus pauvres du monde ?
Cela empirait-il, s'améliorait-il ? Quoi ?
J'ai trouvé la réponse et cela a changé ma vie,
et je veux la partager avec vous.
Voyez --
la plupart des Américains croit que la pauvreté a empiré
depuis que notre enfance depuis qu'ils ont vu cette photo.
Demandez aux Américains
comment a évolué la pauvreté dans le monde,
70% diront que la faim dans le monde a empiré depuis le début des années 70.
Mais voici la vérité.
Voici l'épiphanie qui a changé ma façon de penser.
Entre les années 70 et aujourd'hui,
le pourcentage de la population mondiale
vivant dans la famine,
vivant avec moins d'un dollar par jour, ajusté à l'inflation,
ce pourcentage a baissé
de 80%.
Il y a eu une diminution de 80% de la pauvreté mondiale la plus sévère
depuis mon enfance.
Et je ne le savais même pas.
Ceci, mes amis, est un miracle.
Nous devons le célébrer.
C'est la plus grande réussite anti-pauvreté de l'histoire de l'humanité,
et elle se produit de notre vivant.
(Applaudissements)
Quand j'ai appris cela, j'ai demandé :
qu'est-ce qui a fait cela, a rendu cela possible ?
Car si vous ne savez pas pourquoi, vous ne pouvez pas le refaire.
Si vous voulez le refaire
et sortir de la pauvreté les deux prochains milliards,
car c'est ce dont nous parlons : depuis mon enfance,
deux milliards de ceux-là, nos frères et soeurs,
sont sortis de la pauvreté.
Je veux les prochains deux milliards, donc je dois savoir pourquoi.
J'ai cherché une réponse.
Elle n'était pas politique, car je m'en foutais.
Je m'en fous toujours.
Je voulais la meilleure réponse des économistes traditionnels
de gauche, de droite et du centre.
La voici.
En voici les raisons.
Ce sont les cinq raisons qui font que deux milliards de nos frères et sœurs
sont sortis de la pauvreté depuis mon enfance.
La première : la mondialisation.
La seconde : le libre échange.
La troisième : les droits patrimoniaux.
La quatrième : la règle de droit.
La cinquième : l'entrepreneuriat.
C'est le système de la libre entreprise se répandant dans le monde
après 1970 qui a fait cela.
Je ne suis pas naïf.
Je sais que la libre entreprise n'est pas parfaite
et que la libre entreprise ne suffit pas
à construire un meilleur monde.
Mais elle est géniale.
Et elle dépasse la politique.
Voici ce que j'ai appris, mon épiphanie.
Le capitalisme n'est pas qu'une question d'accumulation.
Son atout principal est l'aspiration,
qui est ce dont beaucoup de personnes parlent sur cette scène,
l'aspiration qui vient des rêves
incorporés dans le système de la libre entreprise.
Nous devons le partager avec plus de personnes.
Je veux vous parler d'une seconde épiphanie
qui est liée à la première
et qui peut nous amener du progrès, non seulement dans le monde
mais aussi chez nous.
La meilleure citation que j'ai entendue
pour résumer les pensées que je viens d'évoquer
pour sortir les gens de la pauvreté
est celle-ci :
« Les marchés libres ont créé plus de richesse
que n'importe quel système de l'histoire.
Ils ont sorti des milliards de personnes de la pauvreté. »
Qui a dit cela ?
On dirait Milton Friedman ou Ronald Reagan.
C'est faux.
Le président Barack Obama l'a dit.
Pourquoi la connais-je par cœur ?
Car il s'adressait à moi.
C'est fou.
Et j'ai dit : « Alléluia ! »
Mais, plus que cela, j'ai dit :
« Quelle opportunité. »
Vous savez à quoi je pensais ?
J'étais à un événement organisé sur ce sujet
à l'université de Georgetown en mai 2015.
Et j'ai pensé que c'était la solution
au plus gros problème de l'Amérique aujourd'hui. Quel est-il ?
C'est de se réunir autour de ces idées,
libérales et conservatrices,
pour aider ceux qui en ont le plus besoin.
Pas besoin de vous dire que nous sommes en crise,
en Amérique et dans de nombreux pays dans le monde politiquement polarisés.
C'est arrivé à un niveau critique de crise.
C'est déplaisant. Ce n'est pas juste.
L'année dernière, il y a eu un article
dans les Procédures de l'Académie Nationale des Sciences,
qui est l'un des journaux scientifiques les plus prestigieux
de l'Occident.
C'était un article de 2014
sur l'asymétrie des motivations politiques.
Qu'est-ce ? Les psychologues appellent cela le phénomène
de la présomption que votre idéologie est basée sur l'amour
mais que l'idéologie de votre adversaire est basée sur la haine.
C'est commun dans un conflit mondial.
Vous vous attendez, par exemple, à le voir entre Palestiniens et Israéliens.
Ce qu'ont découvert les auteurs de cet article
est qu'aujourd'hui en Amérique, une majorité de républicains et démocrates
souffrent d'asymétrie des motivations politiques.
Aujourd'hui, une majorité de personnes politiquement actives pensent
être motivées par l'amour mais que l'autre parti est motivé par la haine.
Pensez-y. Pensez-y.
La plupart des gens disent :
« Mon idéologie est basée sur une bienveillance fondamentale,
je veux aider les gens,
mais les autres sont démoniaques et me veulent du mal. »
La société ne peut pas progresser quand il y a ce type d'asymétrie.
C'est impossible.
Comment résoudre cela ?
Premièrement, soyons honnêtes : il y a des différences.
Ne minimisons pas les différences. Cela serait naïf.
Il y a beaucoup de recherches à ce sujet.
Un vétéran de la scène de TED est mon ami Jonathan Haidt.
Il est professeur de psychologie à l'université de New York.
Il travaille sur l'idéologie, les valeurs et morales de différentes personnes
pour voir leurs différences.
Il nous a, par exemple, montré que les conservateurs et les libéraux
ont une emphase différente de ce qui leur semble important.
Par exemple, Jon Haidt a montré
que les libéraux se soucient à 59% de plus
de la pauvreté que de la liberté économique.
Et les conservateurs se soucient à 28% de plus
de la liberté économique que de la pauvreté.
Des différences irréconciliables ?
Nous ne nous rassemblerons jamais. Faux.
C'est dans la diversité que se trouve notre force.
Souvenez-vous de ce qui nous a sortis de la pauvreté.
C'était une obsession de la pauvreté
accompagnée de la méthode d'une liberté économique
se répandant dans le monde.
Nous avons besoin des autres, en d'autres mots,
si nous voulons aider les gens
et sortir de la pauvreté les deux prochains milliards.
Il n'y a pas d'autre solution.
Comment allons-nous le faire ?
C'est délicat.
Nous devons innover dans notre façon de penser.
De nombreux points sont sur scène.
L'entrepreneuriat social. Ouais. Absolument. Phénoménal.
Nous avons besoin d'investir à l'étranger
de façon durable, responsable, éthique et morale. Oui. Oui.
Mais de quoi avons-nous vraiment besoin ?
D'une idéologie flexible,
moins prévisible.
Non ?
N'avez-vous jamais l'impression que votre idéologie devient prévisible ?
Presque conventionnelle ?
N'avez-vous pas l'impression de toujours écouter des gens
qui sont d'accord avec vous ?
Pourquoi est-ce dangereux ?
Car quand nous parlons d'économie dans ce pays,
à droite, les conservateurs,
vous parlez toujours d'impôts, règlementations, d'un grand gouvernement.
Et à gauche, les libéraux, vous parlez toujours
d'inégalité des revenus.
Ce sont des choses importantes,
très importantes pour moi et pour vous.
Mais quand il s'agit d'aider les gens
qui meurent de faim et ont besoin de nous, ce sont des distractions.
Nous devons nous rassembler autour des meilleures façons
d'atténuer la pauvreté en utilisant les meilleurs outils à notre disposition,
cela ne vient que quand les conservateurs reconnaissent avoir besoin des libéraux
et de leur obsession de la pauvreté,
et les libéraux des conservateurs et de leur obsession du marché libre.
C'est dans cette diversité que réside la future force de ce pays,
si nous le choisissons.
Comment allons-nous le faire ? Comment allons-nous le faire ensemble ?
Il me faut un plan d'actions, pas seulement pour vous mais pour moi.
Numéro un. Premier point :
il n'est pas suffisant de tolérer les gens qui ne sont pas d'accord.
Ce n'est pas assez.
Souvenons-nous que nous avons besoin de personnes qui ne sont pas d'accord,
car il y a des personnes qui ont besoin de nous tous,
qui attendent toujours ces outils.
Qu'allez-vous faire ? Comment allez-vous l'exprimer ?
Cela commence où ? Cela commence ici.
Dans cette pièce, nous sommes tous chanceux.
Chanceux d'avoir des gens qui nous écoutent.
Chanceux de prospérer. Chanceux de diriger.
Quand les gens nous entendent, avec l'idéologie imprévisible,
ils nous écouteront peut-être.
Le progrès commencera peut-être là.
C'est le premier point. Le deuxième.
Deuzio : je vous demande et je me demande
d'être spécifiquement la personne qui brouille la frontière,
qui est ambiguë, difficile à classer.
Si vous êtes conservateur,
soyez un conservateur qui parle toujours de la pauvreté
et de l'obligation morale d'être un guerrier pour les pauvres.
Si vous êtes libéral, soyez un libéral qui parle toujours
de la beauté des marchés libres, utilisés de façon responsable,
pour résoudre nos problèmes.
Si nous faisons cela, nous obtenons deux choses.
Un : nous commençons à travailler pour les prochains milliards
et à être la solution que nous avons vue dans le passé
et dont nous avons besoin dans le futur. Nous obtenons cela.
Et la seconde chose est que nous pourrions être capables
de prendre l'épouvantable sacrée guerre idéologique
dont nous souffrons dans ce pays
et de la transformer en une compétition d'idées
basée sur la solidarité et le respect mutuel.
Et alors peut-être, peut-être,
nous réaliserons que nos grandes différences
ne sont finalement pas si grandes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)